This is a long unit, and I know things are definitely getting tougher.
If you are having trouble I hope you will take advantage of the course forum,
there is lots of great discussions there with other students in the class,
as well as the course staff.
I want to make sure everyone sticks with the class,
so we asked Sergey Brin to explain why you should do that.
[Sergey Brin - Co-founder, Google] [S. Thrun speaking] So will you entice students
to stick with the class and complete it? [both chuckle]
I certainly recommend that you continue with the class
and go all the way through it to completion
to really make sure that you get a deep first cut at computer science and at programming.